[music] they are
constantly working, constantly looking for something
somewhere, they are covering something, well, they are clearly working, they are
scowling, they want to show their strength,
also in Rosetta, the enemy is carrying out
every day, they are flying very often, at this moment they are
pointing more lancets, we are trying to work,
we are trying to detect and
we are trying, of course, to destroy them, well, now
where else how  we started to advance,
now they are working out all the routes to the front
edge so that our armored
vehicles will not
even have a greater ability to deliver
more people, the bull and everything else, therefore, along the
entire direction to the front edge,
artillery works intensively at times, it is necessary to
neutralize their saws so that they
see less of our  movement and our actions
when they blind
We have a nice
[music] [
music]
[music]